Bernie Sanders not a big fan of Bernie
Sanders and I think a lot of young
people who fancy themselves as classical
liberals will talk about that with Dave
Rubin thought like well I'm a classic
liberal but I'm not a social justice
warrior leftist so I support Bernie over
here he's my guy
he's the worst there's ever been he is
the worst pandering you know social
justice warrior every single discussion
is about marginalization than about
entitlement than I think there's ever
been and I'm glad that people are waking
up to it so she know he probably makes
noise when he eats he's about three back
we must grow the middle class yeah you
know now that I think he is I think you
see what Godfrey Bernie he does all the
above the worst offender of them all so
he was sitting down and he was
questioning he was grilling as HuffPo
puts it the Trump's budget chief
Mulvaney I think is his name let's just
go through it so you can see the
absolute insanity of the left see hats
not required the March this is an actual
hearing you wrote a letter stating in
our quote I vehemently urge House
Republican leadership to use every
available tool to strip Planned
Parenthood of any and all taxpayer funds
and take measures to prevent the group
from receiving taxpayer dollars in the
future end quote yes some two and a half
million Americans many of them low
income women well in a second we have to
go to our liberal lexicon here or
leftist lexicon for those who are easily
offended liberal lexicon low income
means brown people or black people
technically black people are brown
people are not really black and we know
that because we've had to light them
here in studio the light meters don't
lie so make sure you understand that
because that's important going forward
next clip now get their health care
through Planned Parenthood at a time
when we have 28 million people who have
no health insurance today despite the
gains of the Affordable Care Act now
despite the gains it's amazing what
gains you can make when you force people
to purchase insurance at gunpoint taken
from other people whose tak
were gathered at gunpoint next club you
really believe that we should tell two
and a half million Americans many of
them low-income women who get high
quality care at Planned Parenthood that
they shouldn't should no longer have
access okay again we have to go back to
the liberal lexicon sorry access in this
instance access as Bernie is using it
actually means free crap
it's important that you get that right
it makes a lot of sense because he's not
talking about no one's talking about
removing one's ability in the private
market to purchase their own birth
control or to purchase their own Jimmy
at abortion is another topic we can get
that that's what Planned Parenthood
largely does is abductions but they
claim that they don't of course Bernie
Sanders will go with that premise we
know it's untrue but access no one wants
to limit anyone's actual access what
they mean it's all making sense is
taxpayer funded free crap next clip it
went a half million Americans many
low-income women choose Planned
Parenthood as their choice for health
care why would you deny them that choice
pause pause choices using that word
again now I know this is easily because
we just talked about this with access
but choice in the liberal lexicon here
as Bernie Sanders is using it also means
Oh free crap yeah this means free crap
why would you deny them access to their
choice what he's talking about is
federal funding for a for an
organization that performs abortions
that's their main seller would have
moved the money from Planned Parenthood
to the federally qualified health care
clinics which are more prevalent more
available and actually serve more needy
women than congressman I know a lot
about the community health centers on
one of the leading advocates for them
here and help increase funding for them
okay of course he just starts to take
credit out of a crease but by the way
when he says increased funding he means
taxpayer dollars yes like he didn't go
out canvassing he didn't go door-to-door
he just saw he signed he co-signed yes
that's a pretty you know IIIi owe
creased funding really made me any
government program that ever came across
your desk where you did an increase
funding Bernie getting your plaque name
on the plaque does not equal he actually
in the funny the Bernie Sanders choose
your own path children's novel it always
leaves to increase funding the never
exciting bonus any other option just
takes you right back so just that's what
you could you just take that phrase
Bernie Sanders increased funding for
blank any bill that ever came before him
or government entity but he wants to
believe that this is somehow virtuous
okay next clip but two and a half
million people mostly women have chosen
Planned Parenthood and after all the
talk about choice that we want a health
care system which allows people to go
anyplace they want your recommendation
is that we should deny two-and-a-half
million women their choice valve yeah
Thank You mr. chairman and you know all
the Bernie Sanders and you're going look
choice and turn it on you birch it's so
silly I mean this is like when people
were outraged at that Donald Trump the
other day reverse the Mexico City policy
he really you believe that saying hey
the United States federal government
should not be funding abortions overseas
is the equivalent to removing your right
to vote because of your uterus this is
what you know before all your talk about
choice yes it still is choice first off
okay let's talk about he's talking about
choice he means free access funded by
the taxpayer it's important people
understand this because they think that
he somehow compassionate no he means
free access funded by the taxpayer and
here's something else if he is even
about choice in reproductive health care
okay if Bernie said he talks about big
banks or Wall Street we're talking about
you know big health care all these
companies that receive bailouts and he
hates and I'm on board with him you know
why you you know what you hate that
because you create super banks you
create super firms right you creates you
create a super insurance companies give
them all kinds of leverage because they
constantly rely on a never-ending supply
of federal bailouts well that's exactly
what happens with Planned Parenthood
it's just big abortion if Bernie Sanders
believes in small businesses he should
want zero federal funding to go to
Planned Parenthood so that the smaller
mom
pop abortion clinics can compete little
Etsy the place they're not even
consistent but the other grades they
come wrapped in twine it's so remarkably
here's the thing the left wants you to
be outraged at the idea that someone who
could be budget chief doesn't want the
federal government to take your money
and give it to an organization whose
main purpose for existing is abortions
they think that that should they're so
out of touch they believe it so
outrageous that Americans are gonna go
who what what someone doesn't want to
take my money from my pocket through
taxes and fund abortion I can't I am
outraged if you like this video
subscribe by clicking the button that
says subscribe if you're not aware of it
now there's no way you're learning the
Internet at this point I'm not going to
help you but this was clipped from my
daily show available exclusively to
lotto with credit com / mug club members
of your student military or veteran
internet promo code it's less than six
dollars a month and you get daily
content no more clips Plus this hand at
smug oh I just when I feel it I got a
chill like on the inside